[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 échos tout de suite le
sommaire de ce magazine
saint-quentin-en-yvelines acteurs de la
mondialisation exportations importations
et de nombreuses entreprises étrangères
présentes sur le territoire
nous recevons marilyne michel directrice
de d link france société taïwanaise
implantée à montigny le bretonneux
attirer des entreprises et ange
étrangères en ile de france c'est le
rôle de paris région entreprises nous
avons rencontré le président de cette
agence régionale franck margain pour
parler du break sites et des
investissements étrangers notamment sur
saint quentin en yvelines
enfin retour sur l'actualité économique
en bref avec le mipim à cannes et le
lancement d'une entreprise éphémère
avant de développer ces titres je vous
propose de faire un point sur le
commerce international dans les yvelines
en 2018
de quel pays sont originaires les
principaux partenaires des entreprises
yvelinoise focus aussi sur les sociétés
étrangères présentes sur saint quentin
en yvelines
regardez l'équipement industriel
matériels de transport voilà les
principaux produits concernés par le
commerce international dans les yvelines
en 2018 les entreprises yvelinoise ont
exporté plus de 8 milliards d'euros de
biens pour des importations atteignant
les 10 7 milliards d'euros
les échanges se font principalement au
sein de l'union européenne
plus de 4 milliards d'euros à l'export
et 12 milliards d'euros à l'import suivi
ensuite par les continents asiatique et
américain premier pays partenaire des
entreprises yvelinoise en 2018
l'allemagne avec un milliard d'euros
d'exportations et 3 milliards d'euros
d'importations le royaume-uni les
etats-unis et la chine sont aussi des
associés importante tout comme l'italie
ou encore l'espagne
bmw mercedes saipem ou d'euros près de
250 entreprises étrangères sont
implantées sur saint quentin en yvelines
un emploi sur dix dépend d'une société à
capitaux étrangers premiers secteurs
d'activité représentés par des sociétés
étrangères l'automobile avec 36
d'établissement autre domaine important
la santé 60% des emplois de cette
filière appartiennent à un groupe
étranger basé sur l'agglomération
et parmi ces entreprises étrangères on
retrouve le groupe de taïwan d link à
montigny le bretonneux et sur notre
plateau nous recevons la directrice
générale de la filiale france marilyne
michel bonsoir bonsoir nicolas alors
déjà est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler
de votre activité des produits que vous
proposez d link est un constructeur de
matériels de raisons informatiques
tu va fêter 33 ans cette année donc on
est sur ce marché depuis un certain
temps on fait donc tout ce qui permet
d'interconnecter des utilisateurs
informatiques des machines aussi on
reste de marché marché des entreprises
pour tout ce qui est infrastructure
réseau les data center le wifi et puis
le marché du grand public également
avec toujours ce besoin de connexion à
la maison puisqu'on a de plus en plus
d'objets connectés et puis on apporte
aussi des objets connectés tube
vidéosurveillance
et puis on voit à travers votre chiffre
d'affaires entre 17 et 18 millions
d'euros c'est quelque chose qui qui
fonctionne c'est un marché qui s'ouvrent
justement le la connexion tout à fait
sûr tous sont de la partie grand public
quand on voit bien aujourd'hui on est
des sujets très importants et beaucoup
de salles où il ya des nouvelles
technologies qui vont venir simplifier
la vie des gens à la maison et c'est
vraiment un marché très porteur
alors d link comme je disais c'est un
groupe taiwanais pourquoi ce groupe
s'est implanté sur saint quentin en
yvelines alors le groupe s'est installé
tout d'abord à paris et puis en
grandissant il fallait parce qu'on avait
besoin d'un stock
à cette époque en france donc bas dans
paris c'est un peu compliqué donc est
arrivé le 78 pas très loin des yvelines
dans une petite ville parce qu'il y
avait un programme pour attirer les
entreprises
et puis très vite non non la ville
n'était pas adapté pour une entreprise
c'était compliqué compliqué d'accéder
les services autour de la ville n'était
pas suffisant donc on a regardé ce qui
se passait dans ce sens 18 et 50 ans
voilà était attractif facile d'accès
pour les employés c'est très important
c'est difficile
de circuler en région parisienne et puis
ces universités ces entreprises qui
étaient déjà aussi implanté on préfère
toujours être vers d'autres entreprises
donc 50 ans s'est imposée très
rapidement un mot sur sur le bric site
on sait que c'est quelque chose qui peut
bousculer au niveau des échanges
notamment avec le royaume uni en quoi
vous pouvez être impactés sachant que
vous vous commercialisez uniquement en
france mais en quoi vous pouvez être
impactés alors nous pour nous bright
site est quelque chose d'assez important
qu'on a un peu anticipé puisque quand
denning c'est importé en europe
comme beaucoup de sociétés étrangères
l'europe c'est d'abord londres facilité
de en terme de langage en angleterre
donc au siège européen est basé à
londres
et pendant très très longtemps notre
stock européen était aussi basé à
londres
donc en 2007 quand ben ayed le
référendum du bric site s'est tout de
suite posé la question de temps dissiper
cette sortie possible du royaume uni de
la communauté européenne et donc qu'on a
anticipé on a déplacé notre stock qui
n'est plus un ballon depuis un an et
demi qui est à rotterdam
on n'a pas été très créatifs mais pour
faciliter vraiment qu'on ait plus de
problème pour livrer nos clients et on
voit bien aujourd'hui la grève de zèle
des douaniers
aurait été un problème pour nos clients
merci marine michel donc affaire à
suivre 1 par rapport à l'impact sur le
bric site mais bon en france on semble
pas trop toucher chez d link en tout cas
merci d'être venu sur notre plateau
focus maintenant sur une pme installée à
montigny le bretonneux est spécialisée
dans les technologies de sécurité
défense à terme s développe et fabrique
des produits pour les exporter à
l'étranger
regardez ce reportage le système
barrière un dispositif de surveillance
des frontières ou de sites stratégiques
principal produits exportés par la
société saint-quentinoise internet 70 %
du chiffre d'affaires de cette pme est
réalisé sur les exportations avec comme
principal client la chine à l'issue de
la réalisation du démonstrateur
franco-chinois barrière nous avons
aujourd'hui des perspectives des jeunes
de 300 systèmes 300 système il faut
savoir que la part d'internet se situe
entre 800 mille et un million d'euros
donc vous voyez sur dix ans 300 millions
de chiffre d'affaires
les prises de commandes pour 2010 9 à
l'export devrait atteindre les 97
millions d'euros burkina faso arabie
saoudite thaïlande la stratégie de
l'entreprise s'appuie aussi sur une
présence locale directement dans les
pays après la vente
ensuite et de créer des filiales ces
mêmes filiales peuvent servir de
plateforme commerciale et d'assurer le
service après vente dans cinq ou six
pays
mais en même temps de prospecter et
d'élargir les possibilités de croissance
de la terme s trois zones géographiques
sont ciblés par à terme s l'asie le
moyen-orient et l'afrique
avec une présence dans 40 pays africains
l'afrique a un gros potentiel dans le
domaine de la sécurité
malheureusement du fait de la situation
sécuritaire du pays et principalement
les pays du sahel
cette année l'entreprise prévoit une
croissance de 30% avec un peu plus de 40
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
objectif dans les prochaines années
dépasser les 50 millions d'euros
[Musique]
accompagner les entreprises venues du
monde entier c'est la principale mission
de lagence paris-région entreprises et
nous sommes avec franck margain le
président de cette structure bonjour
alors commençons avec l'actualité chaude
le bric site je rappelle que on
enregistre cette émission le 15 mars
nous venons de vivre une semaine
cruciale dans ce dossier avec plusieurs
votes à la chambre des communes d'abord
l'accord avec l'union européenne a été
rejetée ensuite les représentants ont
voté pour ne pas faire un break site
sans accord avant de voter pour un
report quel regard vous portez sur ces
événements écoutez c'est un enseignement
extrêmement intéressant pour l'ensemble
des
leaders politiques qui veulent nous
faire comprendre que l'europe est un
enfer moi je pense que nous prenons une
leçon très intéressante de dire tout
d'abord si on veut quitter l'europe
contrairement à ce que tous les leaders
politiques d'extrême droite ou d'extrême
gauche nous a expliqué on ne pouvait pas
donc on voit qu'on peut quitter l'europe
mais on voit aussi que c'est très
compliqué parce qu'on voit en fait que
les liens entre les européens sont forts
si on vient en france et notamment avec
votre rôle de président de paris région
entreprise sinon porte unité leur équipe
alors comme je le dis je suis triste je
me réjouis aucunement bien sûr de ce
brave type mais maintenant je suis dans
une concurrence internationale
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
légalement un très grand nombre
d'entreprises qui sont sur le territoire
britannique qui pour commercer avec le
continent sont obligés je dis bien
obligés d'avoir une base légale sur le
continent et là intervient mon rôle
puisque je suis aujourd'hui en
concurrence avec berlin avec milan avec
amsterdam avec barcelone avec dublin et
donc la région ile de france doit
j'allais dire démontrez l'ensemble de
ses atouts pour attirer ces entreprises
qui sont aujourd'hui sur le sol
britannique et faire en sorte que nous
gagnons la compétition compétition saine
bien sûr un entre les allemands les
italiens les espagnols les hollandais et
bien sûr l'europe de l'est qui joue un
rôle prépondérant dans tout ce qui est
un plan tation industriels le véritable
enjeu du brésil pour nous il est moins
les entreprises qui sont aujourd'hui sur
le sol britannique qui doivent arriver
sur le continent puisque ça nous avons à
peu près cerner le nombre et les flux
qui dans les deux ans vont arriver mais
vous avez un énorme réservoir absolument
colossal et gigantesque d'entreprise qui
aujourd'hui sont à l'international et
qui décide dans leur stratégie de venir
faire des affaires en europe et bien
jusqu il y a deux ans lorsque vous
décidiez dans le monde entier de venir
faire des affaires en europe vous
installiez à londres londres avait un
espèce de réussir une espèce de magie
où l'ensemble des leaders économiques
venez ouvrir un bureau de représentation
ou quelques équipes tout d'abord à
londres avant de voir mais aujourd'hui
il leur faut décider où s'installer et
là où il s'installe est naturellement à
londres ils vont s'installer
naturellement sur le continent alors on
va encore réduire la focale sur saint
quentin en yvelines
le pôle économique en ile de france
est-ce que vous avez des dossiers
aujourd'hui que vous traitez d'ubs rexie
avec des implantations à cause du bric
site sur saint quentin en yvelines
absolument alors je dois dire à vos
électeurs que tout d'abord saint quentin
en yvelines est un élément majeur
d'attractivité de la région ile de
france je dois dire que à la fois bien
sûr la qualité de la vie de nouvelles
mais la qualité de ses infrastructures
de son université de maintenance et
transport attire de manière très
considérable l'oeil des investisseurs
internationaux puisque les années60 ont
souvent quelques critères très simple
d'abord il faut avant tout du terrain du
foncier et bien l'agglomération saint
quentin en yvelines a dit foncier il
faut également des bureaux de haute
qualité environnementale avec les
services qu'on a autrement
et là je dois dire que l'agglomération
de saint quentin a produit des centaines
de milliers de mètres carrés de très
grande qualité j'étais au mipim
d'ailleurs lundi j'ai ouvert le mipim
mardi matin avec les acteurs de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et je dois
dire que la qualité des projets
notamment la géode sur la colline de
guyancourt était un phare sur
l'attractivité alors un projecteur a
développé dans le cadre de déjeuners
donc que je vois bien s'ils voulaient
que l'agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines a bien pris conscience de cette
nécessité d'avoir un d'être attirante
il faut être apte iront économiquement
bien sûr me fouetter de tir on danse on
qualité de vie dans ces infrastructures
dans ces lycées dans ses dents dans la
vie au quotidien
il ya un projet qui est pour vous
certainement un peu connus journalistes
mais qui peut-être moins connus par les
parts par vos auditeurs c'est le
groupe j st jst et le succès de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines puisque c'est
un groupe japonais de très grande
ampleur très sophistiqué puisqu'il
développe l'ensemble de la très haute
technologie en fait pour l'automobile et
avait un très grand nombre de choix de
ville dans lequel il souhaitait
s'implanter en europe et grâce aux
équipes de paris région entreprises
grâce à la présidente madame pécresse et
de l'ensemble
honnêtement des services de la région
ile de france nous avons pu les
convaincre de venir s'installer à saint
quentin en yvelines
bien sûr les équipes de saint quentin en
yvelines ont été très proactive et et la
cellule et économique de 50 ha a fait un
travail remarquable
aujourd'hui c'est un grand soleil
pourquoi parce que c'est un succès qu'on
peut qualifier d'industriels puisque
c'est leur centre de recherche et
développement que sachez que saint
quentin en yvelines et bien sûr dans le
radar des lieux emblématiques de l'île
de france franck m'a rien merci vous
êtes président je rappelle de paris
région entreprises lagence
d'attractivité de la région ile de
france et on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité économique en bref des
yvelinois au marché international des
professionnels de l'immobilier à cannes
un événement du 12 au 15 mars la
possibilité de promouvoir le territoire
et d'attirer de nouveaux acteurs
économiques
saint quentin en yvelines a notamment
présenté les différents projets
immobiliers réalisés ou à venir dans le
cadre de la rénovation du quartier du
centre à montigny le bretonneux
de son côté le conseil départemental des
yvelines a mis en avant sa politique
d'aménagement commune avec celle des
hauts-de-seine myriad c'est le nom de
l'entreprise éphémère lançait à saint
quentin en yvelines le mardi 12 mars
pendant cette semaine 50 demandeurs
d'emploi vont diriger une entreprise à
travers plusieurs services prospection
commerciale auprès d'entreprises
ressources humaines et communication ils
seront encadrés par plusieurs coachs
objectif permettre le retour à l'emploi
rapidement
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]